how's guys my name is Jonah and welcome
to a video about shift the game that I
made for love and air 32 so first of all
for those of you who do not know laden
there is a game programming competition
in which you have 48 hours to make a
game from scratch and you can use
whatever engine you like and yeah you
literally just have 48 hours to win a
game from scratch based on the theme and
the theme this time was an
unconventional weapon so this video is
going to be me talking about my game
that I made which is what you guys are
seeing in the gameplay right now it's
called shift as well as just just a
general review of the competition and
and the game and whatnot so first of all
my thoughts on the themes theme an
unconventional weapon wasn't really
something that I ever kind of liked so I
don't know I thought about it when the
theme I liked pretty much all the time
and let him dare this is my seventh time
doing one in there every time when the
thing comes out I just I just I'm really
not a fan of it most the time he kind of
grows on me but with this one it it kind
of did towards the end there but for a
while and certainly for the first day I
was um I wasn't really too happy with
the theme and I had really had no ideas
I knew I wanted to make a bit of a
platformer and yeah and I kind of that
was kind of the genre I was feeling from
this and I want to make kind of like a a
fighting kind of platform alright so
you'd have like guns and you'd be
shooting everything but then I thought
you know like those weapons are pretty
conventional and that doesn't really
like suit the theme too well so later on
in day 2 I actually ended up coming up
with the idea of well hang on a minute
what if we have a shield and then the
entire game mechanic of how you do
damage to enemies is just by deflecting
what they you know shoot at you and it
was a it was it was an interesting idea
I wasn't quite sure if it was gonna work
out very well and reply even liked it
but this was by now it was the second
day and most of the engine was done so
like most of the end and role coming out
like around this game and whatnot was
done I could generate platforms and
whatnot
can I had a player and I had all the
older player physics and more of it down
and and I was like you know I'll just
throw throwing this mechanic and some
basic AI and see if this works and it
did I really liked it it was a lot of
fun so I just again I expanded on that I
added stages I added score I added
health and whatnot and to be honest I am
really happy with the way that this game
turned out as I mentioned before this is
my seventh time doing let him dare and I
have to say this is probably the most
fun game I've ever made like I've played
this game like a fair few times like
whether it be at work or at home or
whatever like I've played this game a
fair few times like I enjoy playing this
game it's great if you've got like five
or ten minutes and you just want to kind
of relax and whatnot I literally like
have I opened this game and just play it
especially cuz it's um like I'm online
you only need to download it so yeah and
I've never done that with any of my
games for love them down for ever I've
I've pretty much hated them because I've
spent so long developing them and like
they kind of get associated with the
pressure of light and air and the lack
of ideas I have and whatnot so I'm I
really usually am NOT a fan of that but
with this game it was different I found
it really fun which is a really really
good thing anyway all that aside let's
talk about how it was made in one on so
I used my game engine Sparky for this
okay so this is my first time doing a
lot him dare in which I used well any
kind of engine really but basically I
already had a lot of the code for
rendering and whatnot basically it was
pretty much only like there was some
input code and whatnot but the majority
was just I just had like a fast 2d
rendering engine at my disposal okay
that was pretty much it but it was
enough because certainly making
something like Sparky and I had a great
audio engine but actually to be honest
the really the best thing was the fact
that I had not just any kind of engine I
had an engine that I could easily like
make a game for that I could easily
convert into WebGL and to run entire web
browser and that was just that was the
biggest help really I really enjoyed
that so that was that was
that was really good but anyway so I
didn't have to focus too much on the
engine there are heaps of shortcomings
too Sparky that I realized whilst making
this game certainly Sparky was nowhere
near finished at the time of me making
this game and I actually just developed
right in with the engine idle it early
just like right in the engine solution
is where I made this game because I had
to modify a lot of engine code and
whatnot so it wasn't the ideal situation
obviously of making a game using the
spiky engine and whatnot which was fine
I still wanted to use it I'm so glad I
really did like there was nothing like
to my surprise there was nothing
critically wrong with the engine
whatsoever it functioned really well and
I'm quite happy about that because that
would have been not nice during 11:10 to
be like I've imagined no way no I don't
so it did it did end up going really
really well and I'm really happy with
that there are there are tons of things
are in to address in Sparky those will
be covered in a dedicated video for
Sparky so I actually need to put up
about four episodes I think I'm behind
on four episodes like I've already
recorded them in one on I just need to
put them up on YouTube then I think
episode 26 maybe 27 probably I think 26
we'll be talking about lot um death and
I've literally I've got a list of things
that I need to put into Sparky that I
did during want him death okay so I need
to address that during that and whatnot
now as always I wrote the music for this
and produced it in about two hours
so if you guys enjoy that there'll be a
link in description to SoundCloud and
you guys can check that out and download
that music and whatnot if you guys want
I can put up the two-hour video of me
making the music from scratch up on
YouTube I did that last time for lunch
and I've got a pretty good response so
if you guys want that just post a
comment below and and yeah and there'll
be a link below as well to play the game
so you guys will be able to play it now
it doesn't work on Mac okay I'm not sure
about Linux but it does not work on Mac
so Mac people even on WebGL like even
you know inside a web browser for some
reason textured there's a serious error
with textures on Safari for me on Safari
it just it's all black literally like
all the textures of black and white
and then on on a chrome the like it is
like terrible like artifacting and it
just like what it looks like the
textures are just all corrupted so I'll
have to investigate that for Sparky and
whatnot but I'll be fixing that and then
at the end as you can see in your crops
so there you go that was the that was
the great finale but anyway that's my
game I hope you guys enjoyed it again
yeah so my high score here is 67,000 my
high school ever like overall is 188,000
I think so if you guys want to beat that
and post a screenshot of you doing that
that'd be awesome
so yes also the all of the code for let
them dare sorry all of the code for
shift as well is open source of course
and it's you you can find it on my
github repository so it's github.com for
/the churner folds that shift or foot
sorry full /ld 32 there'll be a link in
the description as well of this video
and whatnot but overall I'm really
enjoyed this game and I think it's one
of my best Londonderry games so yeah
anyway if you guys enjoyed this video
please hit like button and I'll see you
guys next time goodbye